in yet another devastating exposure of
the lying of Donald Trump former
national security adviser John Bolton is
now confirming the entire Trump Ukraine
extortion military aide Biden smear
story in his book and Trump is now even
more panicked about preventing john
bolton from testifying publicly I
already told you last week they were
panicking they are very much now
panicking we really need to understand
the scope and the seriousness of this
story because it is almost beyond belief
we are operating in a universe where if
you said to someone living five years
ago and following politics this is what
will be going on in 2020 no one would
believe it as a screenplay it would be
too far-fetched the latest is that john
bolton says in the manuscript for his
upcoming book as yet unpublished that
donald trump straight-up told him
personally
remember Republicans say they want
firsthand witnesses they don't want
hearsay or here Shae as we've heard some
of them say Bolton was told by Trump
withhold the military aid to Ukraine
until they publicly smear Joe Biden I
specifically said last week what John
Bolton needs to do is go public with
what's in the book check out what I said
when I looked when last week it looked
like Republicans were going to try to
obstruct a Bolton from testifying or
make him testify behind closed doors
this is what I said last week I hope
that John Bolton just goes public Bolton
has a book that will be published
sometime this year before the election
even if it's just to sell books
I want Bolton to go public with what he
knows if he's worried that he might sell
more books by keeping the bombshell
revelations only in the book I think
he'll saw way more books by becoming the
guy who goes public rather than the guy
teasing bombshells you've got to buy the
book to see people will reward him for
going public by going out and buying the
book even if they never read it
I hope we see him do it he's not a good
guy but he may be useful to us in this
particular case if he is to simply go
public with what do you know
and what he saw that was last week and
Bolton is doing exactly this if you
believe that he was to some degree
involved in orchestrating the leak of
this of course Bolton's lawyer says we
gave the manuscript to the White House
and then it leaked
we of course have no way of knowing
whether that was part of the plan or
whether it was someone acting at the
White House unilaterally to leak this we
don't know but going public over the
weekend with the bombshell revelations
at every opportunity Donald Trump and
the people around him have come up with
every even remotely possible
hypothetical defense for the crucial
claim and the crucial claim of course is
Trump knew what he was doing he
deliberately withheld aid to push
Ukraine to smear Biden publicly by
announcing investigations into him
they've said this was really Donald
Trump trying to clean up the corruption
in Ukraine that was Trump's concern
Ukraine corruption Trump wasn't aware of
the timing of the aid the aid was
ultimately released and so it couldn't
have been a requirement to smear Biden
since Ukraine never ended up smearing
Biden and they eventually got the aid
well that falls apart given what we know
about when they knew they were now
suspected of doing exactly this they had
no choice ultimately but to release that
aid and on and on and on and of course
we can look at each of those claims
individually and we have and we've
refuted every one of them but this is
john bolton coming in with a storyline
that start-to-finish
refutes all of it right we've been
focused on you know when Trump says the
aid was ultimately released that doesn't
really exculpate them because of this
and because of that Bolton just comes in
and says I was told withhold the aid
until they announced that they're
smearing Biden so understand the
insanity of the upcoming situation that
we find ourselves in in a normal
situation without an impeachment trial
going on if a former national security
adviser made these claims it would
immediately trigger in a pre Trump era
hearings where john bolton would testify
under oath about this okay and alone
this might cause a president to be
impeached we just so happen to have a
Senate
Pietschmann trial going on right now
where there is already a discussion of
having john bolton testify Republicans
plan to argue likely Tuesday or
Wednesday Trump's lawyers are in the
middle of their 24 hours to present
their defense of Trump in the Senate
impeachment trial after that's done
senators will argue and debate which
witnesses will testify who gets a
subpoena which ones will happen behind
closed doors or in public they are going
to try to number one keep John Bolton
out of this altogether which given what
John Bolton is alleging would be
absolutely ludicrous if they can't keep
Bolton out altogether they will either
try to push it behind closed doors or
try to trade Bolton testifying for
pulling in Joe Biden maybe even hunter
Biden they're looking at whether they
want to have the Biden's involved which
of course they should not be and the
dishonesty from the Trump White House is
exposed here as well again how did this
leak while Bolton's lawyer says we sent
the draft of the book to the White House
for review back in December somehow it
was leaked since then that may be true
it may have been a coordinated leak
doesn't matter but what we know is the
White House had a copy of the manuscript
since December and yet throughout
January they continued to lie about what
John Bolton knew and whether John Bolton
did or didn't need to testify and they
continued to tell a story that they knew
John Bolton debunked in his upcoming
book that Trump did nothing wrong that
there was nothing connected between the
aide and Ukraine smears of Joe Biden
there are all sorts of other outrageous
allegations in the book as well which
aren't making headlines and we'll get to
so for example one is according to
Bolton Rudy Giuliani admitted that he
wanted ambassador Murray Ivanovitch
removed because he believed Bolton
believes that Giuliani
realized Jovanovic was obstructing
Giuliani's cronies from doing corrupt
things in Ukraine consider the backwards
the projection there right the whole
idea was Trump and Giuliani they wanted
Jovanovic out because she wasn't doing
enough to fight corruption
in Ukraine it actually appears according
to what John Bolton alleges in his book
that Rudy Giuliani wanted Jovanovic out
because she was interfering in the
corrupt acts of friends and henchmen of
Rudy Giuliani I mean just just imagine
the backwards nature of what is going on
here
people working for Rudy or with Rudy
were the corrupt ones immediate
questions will bolt and testify will
bolton testify in public will we know
about that in the next couple of days
and the question coming on the tail end
of this of course is is this going to
affect whether Donald Trump gets
convicted in the Senate
I still say probably not I believe that
Republican senators will not care we
will be lucky to get four Republican
senators to vote to force Bolton to
testify but I still don't see any path
to a conviction for Donald Trump in the
Senate if you disagree I want to hear
from you let me know I I said this last
week nobody got in touch saying they see
a path to conviction for Donald Trump if
you see one get in touch